answer a part of the most disciplined
dedicated social system on earth until
that is they become slaves to behavior
controlling parasites suddenly these
rogue ants no longer serve the colony
they're taking their orders from the
parasite okay let's back up now how did
this happen it all begins when the ants
in any town USA consume the slime of a
passing snail they divide it up and take
it back to the colony this is a blunder
of epic proportions
turns out the slime is loaded with eggs
of a Body Snatcher called the liver flu
a type of flat worm
the liver fluke burrows into a part of
the ants brain and for unknown reasons
it's almost like the fluke enslaves the
ants and orders them to carry it to
their next hosts any grazing mammal host
with a nice warm liver will do but in
this case a cow appears the liver fluke
worms can switch the ants behavior on
and off causing the infected ants to
place themselves in easy-to-eat
positions at dusk when mammals are
feeding no cows incite ANZAC normal cows
appear ants are in essence ordered to
take their positions in purple flowers
and latch on the cows ingest the
vegetation the ants and the Fluke larva
inside the ants all in one bite once
inside the cow the worms burrow out of
the stomach and into the liver where
they develop into adults and dine on
liver tissue they lay eggs that are
excreted from the liver into the bile
duct and then defecated by the cows they
don't kill the cows but the cows become
weak and emaciated devastating herds and
all because of parasitic mind-control